Nikita bulla is welcoming the newest
addition to her family
she has no regrets about having a second
child she'd always known that one would
never have been enough I've had a boy
yesterday morning so I feel great about
it always wanted to have one of each I
have a elder child she's a girl so I
wanted to have another boy I mean I
wanted her to have a sibling it doesn't
matter but now I have one of each so
nothing better than that it's babies
like nikitas that will soon Propel India
to become the world's most populous
nation projected to overtake China
sometime this year
and while China's population is getting
older India has one of the youngest in
the world
that is good for our economy we'll have
a young Workforce and that is something
which is very very advantageous to us
but the downside is that you know there
is going to be uh the high population uh
puts a constraint on our food on our
health on education
Indian policy makers are hoping that a
young population will Propel the economy
forward just as it did for China in
recent decades
but millions of young Indians entering
the workforce each year will need
millions of jobs as left many
apprehensive about the future
the government should do something to
stop the population growth they should
bring out some rules and regulations
that help control our country's
population when the country's population
is under control only then can we
develop further
it's not good that the population will
be like this in India the government
should do something about it there is
inflation and the population is booming
so the government should provide
Solutions
the next generation of Indians may help
drag Millions out of poverty like China
before it
but it'll be up to the current
generation to start creating policies
that mitigate the problems of an aging
population in the future
Vinton Monahan Al Jazeera